okay now I always teach you fetch when
you arranged when you've got these right
I'll ask you to not just fetch the
different colors but also some that were
the same right something where identical
so I'd like to do a bit of a smoke now
so I've got on I've got three extra
white ones if you didn't fetch something
go get them now what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna rearrange these so we'll reshuffle
the bottom I take three my colors out
like so and replace them with these guys
okay so now my next one is not have
anyway storage in objects but how deep
come in how many ways to arrange in
objects but the difference is I've got
some number of identical elements or
identical objects okay so how many ways
to arrange in objects when now I need
another letting feet for reasons that
will become clear later I'm just gonna
use the matter hey I'm going to just I'm
going to reserve table something special
later so how many ways to range n
objects when a are okay so what you'd
have a look again again when I think
about this just has a set of objects I'm
not worrying about their being identical
the first time I go through and I repeat
this pressure so I'm not going to redraw
it right bless you
I'm not gonna redraw this diagram
because it'll look exactly the same I'm
like oh I just choose I choose I choose
and eventually they fit there we go
eventually I get in order okay so I'm
like look there are 10 factorial ways
that I could do something like this but
then you notice then you notice when you
have a look because the most important
thing that differs from here to the
previous one is clearly these guys right
these guys see this just break them out
for a second okay now these are
technical objects you can see like as an
arrangement right these guys are kind of
their order arrangement there's and this
is an important idea in Arrangements
that you've got like some Arrangements
within of being on set
and you can see these four I can also
put in a particular order do you notice
that now hold on a second
go back to this one how many ways can I
arrange these four identical objects for
factorial right four factorial but as
soon as I do that for example female Oh
what's a different way I could do it
like say maybe I stopped these guys and
then I sort these guys so I've got a new
arrangement except for the fact that
this is exactly the same as all to my to
my highness right is exactly the same as
the arrangement I had before and I can
do this I can rearrange these guys for
factorial ways so therefore I'm not
going to get you want I'm not gonna get
two factorial I'm actually and this is
an important idea I have over the
counter we've over counted this is such
an important another capitalize it we've
over countered by a factor of a
factorial okay so this is different to
when I had a look here and I was like
well how many spots oh my god I still
had to fill up all the spots I still had
the same number of objects right yeah
what do you mean by okay so the idea is
that as far as a part of that problem is
the language were using key right well I
said oh I take out four factorial I'm
dividing by 4 factorial right so one of
the here is all the different ways I can
have this exact same one here and the
white ones are still there it's just
like well the white ones can be
rearranged in four factorial ways and
still be in there and still look the
same to me okay so there's still there
it's not like I have it's not like I've
asked this right so like I've asked this
this is about how many ways to arrange
the six objects which is six factorial
okay but I've done I've got more ways
than that like I've got I'm still
including these guys because remember
right including them in means I can
arrange these guys not just in the order
they're in now but a completely
different spots like for example see how
this guy's second at the moment I could
make him first and that's that's good
morning okay so whereas what you're
thinking of like actually removing these
guys all together and there's leading
with these
that's six factorial but this is still
including I still have 10 spots to fill
I'm still doing this I've just noticed
that some of my lines of 10 look the
same
okay so it's not about arranging less
objects it's around rating the same
number but realizing that some of those
are the same
yep yeah okay so the answer is I don't
need to cook and say because I've
counted all the different ways I can put
them say all together or separate or
like interleaved between them here right
when I just thought about where am I
gonna put these guys it's 10 factorial
it's just that like so I've got I've got
this arrangement and I've also got this
arrangement right
those have been counted here but then
these look identical to some of the
other ways I could do this like in five
yeah that's right if I gave these guys
names right and then and started
realizing they knew they were different
but they took off all of their labels
and well it's the classic sort of like
twins experiment right it's like you
know any of em let's just have the same
pick up from in a while and be able to
swap back and forth um we can tell the
difference okay so that's what I'm
worrying about the positions have been
taken care of here and I'm worried about
the okay so for this one because I over
counted right I started by n factorial
which was 10 factorial in this case but
because I've got too many in the same
way that you argued for me hey you
better be multiplying here not adding to
compensate I'm going to divide that's
the opposite of my multiplication
operation right so that's in factorial
on a metro right now the reason I chose
a is supposed now I did nice to do this
because it's relative suppose I didn't
said okay it's not just rolling up
before I did sequel object I'm at have
four of those and three these okay now I
can still rearrange those four weapons
right but then in addition to that as
well as that I can rearrange these black
lines right so actually I'll put them
separate so you can see them a little
clearer
so when I have a look at this I could
swap this one and this one just start in
two ends right and it would still look
like the same arrangement to me so as
well as doing the eight factorial and
over counted good morning by that factor
I could overcome by a factor of say B
factorial if that was like that might be
three and a factorial and B factor and C
fat or however many identical elements
I'd go okay so maybe you want to make a
move that not only by a factor of a
factorial or etcetera according to how
many kinds of identical right yeah
exactly so for example this one here
would be 10 factorial on 4 factorial 3
factorial right because again think
about this now I had a before remember I
pulled out this 4 and I said hey look
you guys are kind of like they're an
arrangement of it all the same right so
it's like yeah I can pull these guys out
so there's their own set in there and
then after that I take out these guys
and say well they're their own
arrangement 2 and all of their agents
look identical and there will be three
factorial off there does that make sense
so yes I would just keep the money by
however maybe there are according to how
many identical cents
okay very good